[Music]
hey it's your girl miko i'm a food
vlogger over at mikko in the dish and
today tasty has challenged me to use
every item in my fridge to make a
charcuterie board so i'm about to empty
out this fridge behind me and we are
about to make the ultimate charcuterie
board follow along and watch me as i
make this floor
all right so i have my waffle iron
already preheated i sprayed it a little
bit with some cooking oil and all i have
to do is take my biscuit and put it
right on the grate i'm going to close it
and let it cook for three to four
minutes they look beautiful they're
golden brown add my butter here
i also have some fresh fruit that i
found in the fridge so i'm gonna add
some strawberries
some blueberries and got some really
juicy blackberries we're gonna make a
very delicious light and airy fruit dip
so i already have cream cheese in a bowl
i'm going to basically mix this into
it's really light and fluffy now it
looks perfect i'm going to start adding
my remaining ingredients
powdered sugar
i'm going to add just a little bit of
vanilla
now that all the ingredients are in i'm
going to start to whip this until
everything is nice and smooth so i'm
going to add this to a bowl that'll be
good for the sharp creatory board
i'm going to put that right here for now
and so that we can make diy parfaits i
grabbed a little bit of granola that i
had in the pantry so i also had in my
fridge some greek yogurt that's perfect
to go with our breakfast charcuterie
board and it also fits really well with
the sweet side of our board and the way
i'm thinking about setting this up is i
really want to make sure
that the colors or the light colors are
separated so that your eye moves
throughout the board it's looking good
so far we're going to continue to build
up the sweet side and then we'll
eventually get to the savory side i was
able to brown up some mashed potatoes
from last night's dinner and tasty
happens to have a really delicious
looking donut recipe made from mashed
potatoes let's jump right into the
recipe i'm going to add to my flour some
baking powder baking soda
salt
and nutmeg
add in all of my ingredients
coming through nice and evenly now let's
jump into our wet ingredients i have
some room temperature butter here and
i'm going to actually cream until it's
nice and smooth we're going to continue
the creaming by adding in some
granulated sugar brown sugar
and those leftover mashed potatoes i was
telling you about
let's get to freezing
all right that looks good so i have some
eggs i'm going to add the mix
and some vanilla
all right so this batter is coming
together really nicely next i'm going to
do is those dry ingredients that we
first sifted i'm going to add half of
that into the batter so there we go
i'm going to mix this in all together
now i'm going to add my buttermilk
[Music]
that looks good and now i'm going to add
in the rest of my drink
and now i'm going to use a spatula
actually to fold in the remaining dry
ingredients all right our dough is
looking good
get a little bit of flour
now flour is really important because
it's going to keep the dough from
sticking to your surface it's going to
keep the dough from sticking to your
hand you're going to probably add
anywhere from two tablespoons to a
quarter cup of flour as you're kneading
all right our dough looks good it's come
together really nicely now i'm going to
take a rolling pin and we're basically
going to roll this out to about a half
an inch
now we're going to cut our dough i have
a three inch cutter that i'm going to
use so we're going to just press that
straight down and lift up i'm going to
do that all around the entire dough
now i can just lift up my scraps from
around my donut now i'm going to take a
smaller 1 inch cutter and then i'm going
to basically do the same thing in the
very center of each of these donut
circles all right so our oil is ready we
have to wait for it to get to 375
degrees fahrenheit we basically want
these to
be in there
for two minutes on each side
and you can see there are beautiful
beautiful golden brown all right the
donuts look really good i'm going to go
ahead and take these out and i'm going
to add them to a wire rack
and we're going to make a quick cinnamon
sugar just by adding a little cinnamon
to some sugar
i'll stir that up to make sure
everything's equally incorporated it
takes my donut and basically dump it
right inside give it a little bit of
shake and now we have a delicious
cinnamon sugar topping for our donut so
we just wrapped up making these
delicious mashed potato donuts using our
leftover mashed potatoes to complete our
sweet side of the board i have some
peanut butter that i pulled out of the
fridge and i'm going to place this right
here
and i have some leftover peach chutney i
actually made a peach cobbler had a
bunch of peaches left
the sweet pot is looking nice and decked
out but i still have a ton of items that
i need to figure out don't have to make
a vegan maple sausage that is actually
what we're going to use
so i have a little maple syrup
got our black pepper
sage
thyme
garlic powder
and our sauce
i'm going to throw on some gloves to
help me mix this all together
get right in there and basically what i
want to do now is i want to divide this
into eight equal parts in order to make
some pan patties so i'm going to
basically just do a nice soft press into
a little bitty sausage patty just like
that and then add my sausage patty right
inside i'm gonna go ahead and flip these
over we'll give these another two to
three minutes and then they're ready to
go onto our board in order to help with
not staining the board is add a little
bit of paper down first that also is
going to provide some color and some fun
texture that is very interesting to the
eye i love to have a range of cheese
inside of my fridge so we'll add some of
those pieces here as well so let's go
ahead and get right into the candied
beef bacon recipe i went ahead and
created a single layer of all of the
bacon i'm gonna pop that into the oven
my complete house smells like bacon i
can tell that it's ready to pull out
we're gonna
get this pepper jelly that i found in
the fridge it's gonna be really good in
order to add not only some sweetness but
also some spiciness it's nice and
lacquered up with this jelly and so what
i'm going to do is throw this back into
the oven for another three to five
minutes so our candied bacon turned out
phenomenal you can see it's glistening
and all lacquered up with that pepper
jelly i am super impressed already at
what we've been able to do
so i had some deli meat this
traditionally goes into a charcoalery
board and i'll add those throughout the
board as well i am truly working through
all the items in my fridge the last
leftover i have is a steak from last
night's dinner with hubby all i'm gonna
do is add my steak to a
wire
wrap on top of a baking sheet i have my
oven preheated to 250 degrees fahrenheit
i actually had some leftover coffee
butter i know that sounds odd coffee and
steak goes great together i'm gonna add
about two tablespoons of that to my
skillet i'm gonna let that heat up and
then i'm also going to continue to add
my steak into the skillet and then we're
going to let that cook into the coffee
butter give it a little jiggle just to
make sure we're getting all that coffee
butter from the bottom
add it to our wire rack and we don't
want this coffee butter to go away so
we're just going to add what little bit
is left over the top
i'm so excited to add this to my
charcuterie board
boom
and we have coffee butter steak we've
got some spaces to fill in i actually
happen to have some leftover boiled eggs
we have some deli meats that we already
added from the fridge so in the pantry i
went ahead and grabbed a couple crackers
this is truly the ultimate board look at
this i'm actually quite impressed at how
well we did all right if i'm being
completely honest this is what i've been
waiting for
that is incredibly moist on the inside
don't even imagine that you're tasting
mashed potatoes this tastes like a
traditional cake doughnut where do i go
next how about bacon
let me tell you something this bacon
is nice it's crispy and that pepper
jelly is so good it provides that heat
and that sweet is exactly what i need i
am in heaven this is so good first of
all i want to thank you guys for
sticking with me for this full
gargantuan board if you want to see me
make more charcuterie boards here on
tasty leave a comment below let me know
i'm miko and until next time
oh yes
[Music]
you